The cp parameter-- cp stands
for complexity parameter.
Recall that the
first tree we made
using latitude and longitude
only had many splits,
but we were able to trim it
without losing much accuracy.
The intuition we gain is,
having too many splits
is bad for generalization--
that is, performance on the test
set-- so we should
penalize the complexity.
Let us define RSS to be the
residual sum of squares, also
known as the sum of
square differences.
Our goal when
building the tree is
to minimize the RSS
by making splits,
but we want to penalize
having too many splits now.
Define S to be the
number of splits,
and lambda to be our penalty.
Our new goal is to
find a tree that
minimizes the sum of
the RSS at each leaf,
plus lambda, times S,
for the number of splits.
Let us consider this
following example.
Here we have set lambda
to be equal to 0.5.
Initially, we have a
tree with no splits.
We simply take the
average of the data.
The RSS in this case is 5, thus
our total penalty is also 5.
If we make one split,
we now have two leaves.
At each of these leaves, say,
we have an error, or RSS of 2.
The total RSS error
is then 2+2=4.
And the total penalty is
4+0.5*1, the number of splits.
Our total penalty
in this case is 4.5.
If we split again on
one of our leaves,
we now have a total of
three leaves for two splits.
The error at our
left-most leaf is 1.
The next leaf has
an error of 0.8.
And the next leaf has an error
of 2, for a total error of 3.8.
The total penalty
is thus 3.8+0.5*2,
for a total penalty of 4.8.
Notice that if we pick
a large value of lambda,
we won't make many
splits, because you
pay a big price for every
additional split that
will outweigh the
decrease in error.
If we pick a small,
or 0 value of lambda,
it will make splits until it
no longer decreases the error.
You may be wondering at this
point, the definition of cp
is what, exactly?
Well, it's very closely
related to lambda.
Considering a tree
with no splits,
we simply take the
average of our data,
calculate RSS for
that so-called tree,
and let us call that
RSS for no splits.
Then we can define
cp=lambda/RSS(no splits).
When you're actually
using cp in your R code,
you don't need to think
exactly what it means-- just
that small numbers of cp
encourage large trees,
and large values of cp
encourage small trees.
Let's go back to R now,
and apply cross-validation
to our training data.